voilà tout est fait l'amour au total
alors c'est où j'en sais rien on serait
déclassée mois passés à tes classiques
bas donc sur la table mais ça c'est
décevant jean-michel un peu partout dans
un sous la norme dans un chemin j'étais
tout seul mais mais dans un avion allait
sans aucun censeur non mais un ascenseur
à 3 et de la fille un ascenseur à 3d oui
c'était très rapide abc bah oui non
j'suis pas mentalement rien
d'extraordinaire arrête ne me dis pas qu
c'est ça ta jamais fait un truc aussi ce
way avec avec ça mais sexuelle de
l'audiovisuel csa mais c'est quand même
d'aller au fond de la mer avec des
bouteilles à la mer
keynes caen-la-mer à la mer l'océan
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
son l'océan non mais tu es tu en as tu
des frères ben j'ai décrit bouteilles
d'oxygène n'a pas besoin de maçons soit
besoin je sais julien doreau ya des gars
qui amène les poissons et passants des
cascades et des sons pas commencé leur
colère ils vont des us comme ça avec les
new way alors donc au fond d'eux au fond
de l'océan à 20 mètres donnant leur
taille qui va t il perdre une personne
voilà comme un vrai pro comment vous
avez eu l'idée vous est fixé à bercy
c'était un fantasme ce qu elle s était
pas là parce qu'on avait plus que cette
fois sur c'est un poisson dont sept
longueurs
la mère d'arrêter jeu concours avec vous
dans gouin mais pour moi c'était que
c'est au fond de la mer oui j'aimerais
le faire j'avais ça se trouve c'est très
érotique parce qu'il est grande à la
bouteille sur le dos on aura problème
avec lui c'est que c'est pas le grand
bleu tout le petit bleu si tout le monde
soit dans une bonne phase avec un site
basé sur un chemin de grande randonnée
scouts on n'avait pas vu on est en panne
et battant tous les scouts de 10 ans
même dix ans ont passé
non ah ouais à l'épargné ont voulu en
vous d'accord merci à dieu est une belle
anecdote on n'est pas intéressant non
non non non non non non je vois bien
rester courtois
je reste courtois dans un camion de la
propreté de paris quoi oui absolument
des camions pour nettoyer
ils ont fait pour un déchet ont foutu
dedans on sortait de boîte de nuit avec
des cadenas priorités de paris qui était
là y'en a qui étaient ouverts encore
reconnaît rentrer dans lequel nos
propres idées de paris comme ça c'est
grand c'est le grand calme ou une
banquette arrière
c'est rigolo clavel gyrophares et où
c'est marrant c'est vrai
[Rires]
saguenay synchro avez-vous moncla cilic
a dit j'ai fait chaque écoute amour non
longtemps ah ouais bah oui mais c'est
normal c'est tellement doucement le nom
n'ont jamais de truck driver syrie tout
ce bras oui c'est pas l'amour série ne
fait pas l'amour non ça fait oui fait
depuis maintenant des moines oui ils
distribuent de bonheur et distribué
l'axé commenté eu des enfants quoi
comment tenir à l'écouté sur la question
oui oui beaucoup élevé d'obésité un don
de dieu les enfants quelques livres
novelli classique où ça lee c'est
toujours un bon joueur
bah ouais c'est vrai bon alors et toi
amérique
mais on dit la vérité si osi tout dans
la voiture assétou koné 6 sa voiture ses
classiques belges plage
ouais attendait parce que plus ça va
puis comment
[Applaudissements]